[Música]
salud de directo américa de france 24
más o menos a la ya lista conmigo en el
estudio mar vamos a hablar de la
desigualdad de la pandemia el cuit 19 en
nuestra región no si efectivamente en
américa latina porque hay un informe que
se publicó la semana pasada ha hecho por
amnistía internacional y también por el
centro por los derechos económicos y
sociales donde básicamente enunciaban
mientras que américa latina tenía el
obtiene el 84 por ciento de la población
mundial acumula el 28 por ciento de las
muertes globales de covite 19 esto lo
achacan a la desigualdad que se vive en
la región estamos con erika guevara
rosas directora para las américas de
amnistía internacional vemos que esta
cantidad de muertes es desproporcionada
no ustedes apuntan a la desigualdad como
uno de los principales motivos como
opera ese mecanismo
bueno este informe analiza 17 países
analiza información estadística
cuantitativa pero también cualitativa y
podemos determinar que efectivamente las
grandes desigualdades sociales y
económicas han sido una de las claves
para entender por qué la pandemia de
kobe 19 pues se encuentra tierra fértil
de nuestra región para convertirla en el
epicentro de la pandemia por todos sus
impactos es claro ver que un gran
porcentaje de la población de américa
latina y el caribe no cuenta con acceso
al derecho a la salud porque los propios
estados no han hecho una inversión
adecuada a ninguno de los gobiernos de
nuestro continente e
invierte lo que recomienda la
organización panamericana de la salud
que es el 6% del producto interno bruto
en el servicios de salud pública brasil
y chile- que son los dos principales
países que invierten en salud pública ni
siquiera alcanzan el 4.5 por ciento lo
que nos pone al descubierto
efectivamente que ha sido un cúmulo de
falencias naturales pero sobre todo
estas desigualdades en el acceso a
derechos humanos que finalmente pagamos
o todos los ciudadanos de nuestra región
de américa latina y el caribe de por
todo lo que estábamos conversando eric a
la salud o muy buenos días le pregunto
entonces cuáles son los países que se
han visto más afectados
bueno es raúl hay una relación estrecha
entre los países que acumulan el mayor
número de personas que han fallecido ya
sean en números absolutos o en números
en términos comparativos per cápita son
los países que también tienen las
brechas de desigualdad más grande
estamos hablando de países como méxico
brasil perú chile en donde efectivamente
estas desigualdades que se ven entre
entre la concentración de la riqueza que
tiene un poco porcentaje de la población
pero también entre esta falta de acceso
a servicios de salud pública en países
en donde un limitado porcentaje de la
población tienen acceso a salud
universal
precisamente hablando de ese pequeño
porcentaje de población no también el
informe destaca cómo hay grupos que
históricamente son más marginados como
por brecha de género por veces por
brecha racial también que es lo que
sucede para que estas personas tengan
menos acceso a la salud cuáles son los
motivos por los que también han muerto
más por kobe 19
bueno eso es bien importante mencionar
que la inequidad de género y el racismo
juegan un papel determinante son una de
las claves que nosotros desarrollamos en
el estudio verdad en el análisis en esta
investigación es precisamente que el
grupos históricamente marginalizados
como nuestros pueblos indígenas las
comunidades negras las mujeres y niñas
que viven en situación de pobreza las
comunidades rurales son quienes han sido
afectadas es proporcionalmente por la
pandemia de kobe 19 pero no sólo en
términos de la emergencia sanitaria sino
también han sido afectados
desproporcionadamente por estos
porcentajes altísimos este número de
personas que se unen al grupo de
personas que viven en situación de
pobreza la cepal establece que 14
millones a partir del que se declara la
pandemia se han unido a este grupo y que
16 millones han caído en pobreza extrema
es que también eric a esta pandemia ha
hecho crecer esta pobreza de la que
estamos hablando a futuro esto va a
impactar en el acceso a la salud de las
más minerales
en efecto va a afectar porque en muchos
de nuestros países sólo por ponerte un
ejemplo chile es un país que el 50 por
ciento de los recursos que se destinan a
salud pública provienen del propio
estado pero el otro 50% proviene de los
bolsillos de las personas es decir a
través de sus contribuciones voluntarias
o su pago o pago verdad e inclusive en
la seguridad pública entonces son estas
personas que a través de la carga
tributaria de estos sistemas regresivos
que sólo cuentan con el ivai que sabemos
que tiene una carga en las personas más
pobres y que además tienen que
contribuir a su propia salud pues van a
estar pues mayormente afectados bajo
estas normas verdad que no están
proveyendo de salud pública para todas
las personas por supuesto y también
desde el periodismo tendremos que seguir
pendientes de cómo afecta así hayamos
dejado el tapabocas como sigue afectando
la pandemia en otros términos también en
términos de desigualdad de pobreza y de
acceso a la salud así es el mar
muchísimas gracias también por supuesto
a ti erika gracias por estar con
nosotros en este espacio de salud en
directo américa erika a que verás rosas
directora para las américas de amnistía
internacional
este informe las desigualdades de la
pandemia era quemar las invitó entonces
a que continúe con nosotros para ver a
nuestra segunda invitada